Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft,
mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe Nummer 69 unserer Gesprächsreise durch die wissenschaftlichen Welten.
Wo man immer mal wieder so auf Themen stößt, die man vielleicht gar nicht so erwartet hätte, die ich auch nicht so erwartet hätte
und die vor allem auch mal in Bereiche einen Einblick bieten, die man so normalerweise nicht so aktiv wahrnimmt.
Und so ein Beispiel haben wir, glaube ich, heute.
Heute reden wir über den Islam bzw. eigentlich reden wir über die Ästhetik des Islam und der muslimischen Welt.
Und dazu begrüße ich meine Gesprächspartnerin, nämlich Alina Kokoschka, hallo.
Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist.
Ja, Islamwissenschaftlerin, stimmt oder?
Genau.
So kann man das sagen?
So heißt es, ja.
So heißt das.
Also zumindest hier.
Hier in Berlin.
Ja.
Genau.
Sie sind ein Postdoctoral Research Fellow, was heißt das eigentlich genau?
Ja, das heißt also, dass man eben nach der Promotion oder diese Postdoc-Phase, postdoctoral Phase nach der Promotion ist dazu gedacht,
dass man sich weiteren Forschungen widmet, im Idealfall natürlich Richtung Habilitation, aber faktisch sind da viele Leute so auf der Suche
oder orientieren sich nach der Dissertation erst mal neu.
Und das Ganze an der Graduate School for Muslime Cultures, schön auf Englisch.
Genau, Muslime Cultures and Societies.
And Societies.
Genau, die hat einen internationalen Ansatz, so wie alle graduierten Schulen, die, meine ich, 2006/2007 entstanden sind infolge der Exzellenzinitiative.
Und daher sind die alle auch, also Englisch ist die Kommunikationssprache auch.
Und genau, da bin ich assoziiert noch und habe dort eben promoviert.
Mhm (bejahend).
Ist das jetzt konkret an eine Universität angeschlossen oder hat das eine gewisse Eigenständigkeit?
Das ist an der FU beheimatet, ist aber eine Kooperation mit der Humboldt-Universität, dann mit, jetzt hoffe ich, dass ich niemanden vergesse, mit dem Zentrum moderner Orient,
wichtige Forschungseinrichtung auch in Berlin, und jetzt habe ich sicherlich jemanden vergessen, aber es geht über die FU-Grenzen hinaus.
Ist aber eng angeschlossen ursprünglich oder in der Grundidee an die Islamwissenschaft an der freien Universität, daher, glaube ich, auch dort die Beheimatung.
Und ist das eine wünschenswerte Umgebung, also ist das sozusagen im Ergebnis hilfreich?
Ja. Also, ich glaube, promovieren ist immer eine Qual, aber da ist man nicht allein mit der Qual, also das ist, glaube ich, das Angenehme, dass man zum einen nochmal Seminare besucht,
also es ist im Grunde nochmal ein kleines Studium.
Die Seminare sind so, ich glaube, vor allem im ersten Jahr und dass man aber diese Community hat.
Also man hat die eigene, Kohorte heißt das dort, aber den eigenen Jahrgang, man trifft sich mit den Leuten, man hat eben „Verbündete“, sage ich mal.
Und dadurch, dass das so institutionalisiert ist, ist man nicht so allein gelassen und ich denke, beim Promovieren hören viele Leute auch wieder auf
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, glaube ich, geringer, wenn man so eingebunden ist.
Okay, aber wenn das postdoctural ist, dann haben ja da viele auch schon ihren Doktortitel.
Ach so, da haben schon viele es abgeschlossen, ja.
Und da geht es dann sozusagen weiter.
Jetzt würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, wie man in dieses Themenfeld gerät, da muss man ja irgendwann mal Lust drauf gehabt haben, wie war denn das bei Ihnen?
Ja, diese Frage wurde mir oft gestellt.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, und ich finde immer neue Antworten.
Dann mal los.
Also ganz ursprüngliche Antwort wäre vielleicht, ich war auf einer Grundschule mit einem hohen Anteil von Schülern, die aus der Türkei kamen.
Auch in Berlin?
Nee, in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Und ich habe viele Freundschaften da gehabt und dazu eine Grundschullehrerin, eine Klassenlehrerin, die mit uns in die örtliche Moschee gegangen ist,
zu irgendwelchen Projekttagen oder so und die hat auch andere Sachen mit uns gemacht, aber es gab irgendwie so keine Berührungsängste und für mich war das alles ganz positiv besetzt.
Dazu kam, dass mein Vater früher dorthin, also in die Türkei, gereist ist und auch Interesse an Nordafrika hatte, das hat sicherlich auch so eine Grundlinie mitgegeben oder ein Interesse.
Und ausschlaggebend war dann, das ist mir erst nach der Doktorarbeit wieder eingefallen, war, dass ich in der Abizeit ein Bildband mit islamischer Architektur in der Hand hatte und dachte,
ahja, das will ich machen, ich weiß nicht genau, was es heißt und wohin es mich führt, aber das will ich machen.
Und dieser Brückenschlag zur eben Gestaltung, zur Architektur, zur Ästhetik, der kam aber erst wieder eigentlich in der Promotion.
Und dieses ganze Studium über hat mich das, ja das hat mich sicherlich gestützt dabei zu bleiben, weil ich einfach viele Dinge schön fand, aber im Studium habe ich mich gar nicht damit beschäftigt.
Ich finde das ja immer bemerkenswert, dass wir gerade in Deutschland so einen hohen Anteil türkischer Mitbürger haben, aber es eigentlich nirgendwo eine Schule gibt, wo auch mal Türkisch unterrichtet wird.
Das wäre doch eigentlich ganz hilfreich gewesen oder?
Ja, das wäre wahnsinnig hilfreich.
Das wäre ja auch, also sowohl Arabisch als auch Türkisch, aber Türkisch liegt noch näher an Deutschland, aber es wäre auch deshalb hilfreich,
weil die Menschen besser verstehen würden, warum zum Beispiel jemand, der gebrochen Deutsch spricht, und einen türkischen Hintergrund hat,
warum der auf diese Art gebrochen Deutsch spricht und dass der nicht blöd ist, sondern dass einfach die türkische Grammatik ganz anders ist
und deshalb zum Beispiel es nicht, ich Schüler, also das Verb oft fehlt.
Nicht sagt, ich bin Schüler oder ich bin neu hier, sondern, ich neu, ist nicht, weil jemand nicht sprechen kann, sondern weil es im Türkischen wie auch im Arabischen so gebildet wird.
Ah.
Und deshalb würde so ein Sprachverständnis auch die kulturelle Verständigung auch sehr fördern.
Ja. Ist ja ein interessanter Einfluss.
Ich glaube, man nennt das Kurzdeutsch, was sich jetzt sozusagen herausgebildet hat.
Was ja auch so eine Feststellung ist, dass es ja eigentlich auch mit weniger Worten geht.
Ich würde das jetzt nicht unbedingt bejubeln, aber die Dinge sind halt so wie sie sind und am Ende ist ja auch Sprache nur ein Ausdruck individueller und kollektiver Weiterentwicklung.
Und in dem Moment, wo die Kommunikationsebene funktioniert, dann funktioniert sie halt und da wo sie eben optimiert werden kann, tut sie das eben.
Und ja heute sagen halt auch viele Deutsche, ja ich geh Aldi und dann weiß eigentlich auch jeder was gemeint ist.
Ob das jetzt dem persönlichen ästhetischen Empfinden dann immer gerecht wird, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Ja, ich denke, das ist wichtig und natürlich ist ja diese Arbeit als Islamwissenschaftlerin auch sehr geprägt von diesem fehlenden Verständnis oder eben auch der Suche danach.
Ja. Also das ist mir ein großes Anliegen, dass ich das Gefühl habe, also dass da falsche Bilder im Umlauf sind, vereinfachende Bilder, Bilder, die Islam als vorrangig etwas darstellen, was verbietet, einschränkt…
…rückständig.
Rückständig ist, ausgrenzt und das ist eine kleine Facette.
Die wir ja auch im Angebot haben, so ist es ja nicht.
Die haben wir im Angebot, natürlich, die muss man sich auch gut angucken und irgendwie einen Weg finden damit umzugehen.
Aber das ist so, als würde man sich nur die Evangelikalen anschauen und damit aussagen, wie das gesamte Christentum ist.
So sind alle Christen, genau.
Was sicherlich dann auch getan wird aus der anderen Perspektive heraus.
Ja, da haben Sie recht.
Wenn die Agenda passt.
Ja, jetzt ist ja im Zentrum Ihrer Forschung, wie wir schon gesagt haben, das Kulturelle.
Also das, was sich aus der islamischen Kultur auch an konkreten Dingen heraus ergeben hat.
Architektur fiel schon, aber es geht ja noch drüber hinaus.
So insbesondere die moderne Produktwelt ist so ein bisschen in Ihren Fokus geraten.
Also wie kam es sozusagen zu dieser Ausrichtung?
Weil wenn man sich mit Islam an sich beschäftigt, dann kann man erst mal Islam als solchen verstehen, Sprachen lernen, ich weiß gar nicht, was alles in dem Studienpaket so drin ist.
Und ich denke mal, das hat auch erst mal sehr viel mit dem Alten zu tun, der Geschichte zu tun, dem tradierten großen primär wahrgenommenen Islam.
Genau.
Bis man da überhaupt auf so eine modernere Schiene gerät.
Man lernt Arabisch und noch eine zweite Sprache, war bei mir Türkisch, aber das Arabisch ist unerlässlich, weil es eben die Sprache des Koran ist,
weil die Sprache einen derart zentralen Stellenwert im Islam hat und für Muslime.
Und da liegt es nahe, hat aber auch viel mit der europäischen Wissenschaftsgeschichte zu tun, dass man sich sehr auf die Texte fokussiert hat.
Und Islamwissenschaft war sehr lange Textauslegung.
Und das hat auch noch immer seine Berechtigung und ist das, was Islamwissenschaft jetzt unterscheidet von, ich kann mich ja auch als Ethnologe mit muslimischen Kulturen beschäftigen,
aber als Islamwissenschaftler habe ich eben immer die Rückbindung an die Quellen, sprich den Koran, aber auch die Sunna, die Prophetentradition und andere Texte,
die je nach Ausrichtung im Islam so dazugekommen sind.
Sunna ist was?
Sunna ist die Prophetentradition, das ist Sammlung von Hadithen.
Hadithen sind so eben übermittelte kleine Verse, ja Verse ist wahrscheinlich der falsche Begriff, aber da trifft eben Mohammed Aussagen darüber
zum Beispiel, dazu werden wir vielleicht noch kommen, dass dort wo ich bete keine figürlichen Darstellungen auf den Stoffen sein sollen,
also auf den Teppichen, auf den Kissen, weil die ablenken vom Gebet.
Daraus zum Beispiel wurde das omnipräsent, so als omnipräsente wahrgenommene Bilderverbot abgeleitet,
was aber eigentlich gar keine Grundlage hat, es gibt kein Bilderverbot im Islam, sondern es gibt diesen Vers, diesen Hadith von Mohammed,
dann gibt es eine große Technik, wie man nachprüft, also wie in der islamischen Theologie nachgeprüft wird, welcher Hadith jetzt besonders tragfähig ist,
also welcher besonders verlässlich ist.
Ist das Teil des Korans oder ist das separat?
Nein, nein, das ist ein Textkorpus, der separat ist und der wird auch nicht von allen, da gibt es wieder verschiedene Rechtsschulen
und nicht alle Rechtsschulen einigen sich auf genau den gleichen Korpus und der spielt vor allem für Sunniten eben eine große Rolle.
Eben als Gesamtkorpus heißt der Sunna, das ist die Tradition, Tradition des Propheten und die ist eben für Sunniten vor allem ausschlaggebend.
Im Studium selbst steht der Koran im Zentrum.
Und auch den studiert man jetzt nicht von A bis Z und von der ersten Sure bis zur letzten,
aber es ist immer wieder wichtig zu schauen, wenn man sich mit einem Phänomen beschäftigt, wie ist da eigentlich die Quellenlage?
Also worauf kann sich ein islamischer Gelehrter beziehen oder worauf haben sich islamische Gelehrte immer wieder bezogen?
Oder wenn ein Rechtsgutachten erstellt wird, eine Fatwa, weil zum Beispiel junge Muslime sich piercen lassen wollen,
dann müssen die Gelehrten schauen, wo gibt es in diesen islamischen Quellen eine Stelle, die darauf hinweist, dass das möglich ist oder verboten
und aus welchen Gründen und wie kann man das, ist das dann vielleicht nur geduldet, aber nicht erwünscht, ist es aber verboten
oder kann man sagen, ach ja könnt ihr machen wie ihr wollt.
Und da gibt es immer ein ganz große Bandbreite wie man das auslegt.
Also es ist ganz viel Textauslegung.
Das ist ein ganz interessanter Bereich dieses Rechtsverständnis.
Wie muss man das sehen?
Es wirkt ja, also gerade Fatwa ist ja auch ein Wort, was ein bisschen Schaden genommen hat durch die Fälle von Salman Rushdie,
was man halt so im Westen immer primär wahrgenommen hat, was dann halt immer mehr so als Fluch wahrgenommen wird.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, welche Bedeutung oder in welcher Form sind Rechtsverständnis, Rechtsgültigkeit und eben Tradition und Religion miteinander verkoppelt?
Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass wir das so mit unserem weitgehend sekulären Verständnis der westlichen Welt so gar nicht richtig zusammensortiert bekommen.
Genau, das Problem ist, ich sage jetzt mal Problem, in der Wahrnehmung ist, dass beispielsweise wenn die Leute über die Scharia sprechen
und oh Gott oh Gott, da möchte jemand die Scharia einführen, dass in der Scharia eigentlich relativ wenig …
Die Scharia ist genau was?
Na das sind die rechtlichen Vorgeben, die sich aus dem Koran ableiten lassen, wo zum Beispiel steht, kein Schweinefleisch, kein Fleisch vom Aas,
also von schon gestorbenen Tieren, essen.
Da steht kein Alkohol, ihr sollt nicht berauscht zum Gebet geben, Ehebruch, Diebstahl, das sind so Dinge, die sind fest,
weil sie eben so eindeutig sich in diesem Textkorpus belegen lassen oder immer wieder darauf rückbeziehen lassen, der von allen geteilt wird.
So ein bisschen wie zehn Gebote?
Ja, nur dass da nicht 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 steht.
Ja.
Aber so von der Gültigkeitsbedeutung.
Aber…
Genau, ja.
Und dann gibt es diesen ganz ganz weiten Bereich des Gewohnheitsrechts, der auch anerkannt ist als eine Quelle oder ein wichtiges Element,
wenn man in einer konkreten Gesellschaft schaut, wie da die Rechtssprechung sein soll.
Aber das ist eben nicht schriftlich verbrieft, sondern das ist eben wie der Name sagt Gewohnheitsrecht.
Und da ist schon ein großer Unterschied zu machen im Begriff, weil im Christentum haben wir halt das Christentum und wir haben Christen.
Im Islam aber haben wir den Islam und wir haben Muslime, das sind schon zwei verschiedene Worte, die kommen aus dem gleichen Wortursprung.
Aber der Islam ist die Religion und Muslime sind eben die es glauben, die es praktizieren, das heißt, es gibt immer diese zwei Elemente dessen,
was sozusagen textlich schriftlich per Offenbarung gesetzt ist und dann gibt es diese Welt der Praxis.
Und die Welt der Praxis ist eigentlich das, was mich immer besonders interessiert hat, die man nicht losgelöst von diesen Grundregeln sehen kann,
weil sie daraus sich ganz viel speist und immer wieder damit auseinandersetzt, aber daher heißt diese Graduiertenschule auch Muslime Cultures und Societies,
weil es eben nicht um islamische Theologie geht, sondern es geht um gelebtes muslimisches Leben.
Und deshalb haben mich Objekte des täglichen Gebrauchs interessiert, eben Waren, weil ich irgendwann festgestellt habe bei meinen Reisen nach Syrien
und Forschungen in Syrien, da gibt es plötzlich so ein Warenangebot, Lampen, auf denen die Kaaba, also dieser schwarze Würfel in Mekka, ist,
der sich dreht, wenn man die anmacht und überall glitzert es.
Oder Gebetskleidung in rosa für Mädchen, dazu eine Puppe, dies ist ein sehr prominentes Beispiel, eine Puppe, die fast genauso aussieht wie die Barbie,
aber eben zusätzlich zu ihrem sportlichen Outfit so ein Verschleierungsoutfit hat, wenn sie nach „draußen“ geht.
Muslime Barbie.
Genau.
Und dann daraus hat sich dann ein Gebetsset für Mädchen abgeleitet, was die dann real tragen können, so in rosa Satin.
Und plötzlich gab es eben viele dieser Dinge und ich war ein bisschen irritiert, weil ich das nicht kannte.
Ich kannte nicht Waren im Angebot, die irgendeinen religiösen Bezug haben.
Gibt es wieder im evangelikalen Umfeld mehr, haben wir hier aber nicht, also das ist mir unbekannt gewesen.
Und das hat für mich so ein …
Aber war es auch im eigentlichen Sinne neu?
Genau, es war neu, hat damit zu tun, dass beispielsweise in Syrien, aber auch in anderen Ländern, eben der politische Islam,
der so in den 70ern, 80ern versucht hat Aufwind zu gewinnen, sich anders orientieren musste,
weil es beispielsweise in Syrien viele Repressionen gegeben hat und der Staat auch einen neuen Umgang damit gesucht hat,
wie kann man eigentlich diesem Bedürfnis der Menschen, Gluaben zu leben, gerecht werden, aber denen nicht zu viel Einfluss geben,
weil man ja sein System aufrecht erhalten will und da hat sich vieles eben auf das private Leben verlagert und gleichzeitig in die Sichtbarkeit nach außen.
Und dazu gab es dann plötzlich eine Ausdifferenzierung von Dingen, die die Leute gerne gekauft haben, weil sie damit auch zeigen konnten, wo sie stehen
und weil es oft auch Dinge waren, mit denen man real wirklich zum Beispiel sich am Leben des Propheten orientieren kann.
Also sehr prominentes Beispiel, in der Sunna, also dieser Prophetentradition, von der wir eben sprachen, wird berichtet,
von einem Prophetengefährten, dass Mohammed immer ein Zahnhölzchen benutzt hat, Miswāk, und das gibt es auch im Ayurvedischen,
das ist vom sogenannten Zahnholzbaum, so heißt der auch auf Deutsch und wenn man darauf kaut, dann fasert der so auf
und mit diesen herauskommenden Fasern kann man die Zahnzwischenräume reinigen und zugleich wirkt es irgendwie antibakteriell.
So das benutzen heute viele Muslime, die sich sehr nahe am Leben Mohammeds orientieren wollen.
Und für die, die aber keine Lust haben, auf diesem Hölzchen zu kauen oder gar nicht wollen,
dass sie so nah an den Sunniten, die so nah auch am Mohammed-Leben sein wollen, orientieren, also Salafiten oder so,
die benutzen vielleicht eher die Zahnpasta, die diesen Extrakt benutzt.
Und plötzlich gab es also diese Zahnpasta, die gab es vorher nicht.
Das heißt, wir waren ja gerade noch so ein bisschen bei diesem Rechtsverständnis.
Ich sehe hier gerade so ein bisschen so ein, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Art Dreieck, also Religion auf der einen Seite,
Rechtsverständnis und damit sozusagen auch gekoppelt natürlich auch die Ableitung, was gilt in diesem Land?
Also was ist quasi das politische System?
Ich denke, das kann man jetzt gar nicht so stark voneinander trennen, weil ja dann letzt Endes die Rechtssprechung auch die Ordnung
in dem jeweiligen Land auch definiert.
Und dann eben so dieser freie kulturelle persönliche private Bereich der individuellen Lebensgestaltung,
der irgendwie versucht, mit diesen anderen beiden Rahmenbedingungen klarzukommen,
die aber beide typischerweise sehr viel mehr eingreifen eigentlich in das private Leben, sehr viel mehr Regeln, das ist jetzt auch eine Frage, ob das so ist.
Aber so nehme ich das jetzt gerade wahr.
Da gibt es irgendwie eine Menge Dinge von, was man tun darf, was man nicht tun darf, wann man es tun darf etc. pp.,
mehr als wir das jetzt in unserem Kulturraum jetzt haben, also zumindest jetzt hier in Deutschland.
Kann man das so sehen, dass das so ein Spannungsfeld ist aus diesen drei Polen?
Die Reglementierung meinen Sie von Seiten des Staates oder aus der Religion?
Ja, sowohl als auch.
Von beiden ja.
Also das sind sozusagen diese beiden Elemente und dem steht dann quasi so die individuelle private Lebensgestaltung entgegen
und dann ist dieses Konsumverhalten dann auch ein Ventil und ein Versuch, eben mit beiden Systemen in irgendeiner Form klarzukommen.
Ja, so kann man es auf jeden Fall auch sehen, aber das nur so als Ventil zu betrachten oder also so etwas …
das ist schwierig.
Also es hat natürlich etwas oppositionelles, gerade in Syrien hat es etwas oppositionelles gehabt, wurde, glaube ich, lange nicht ernst genommen,
weil es eben oft rosa ist und Herzen drauf sind, also es hat etwas verspieltes gehabt, das, was man dort kaufen konnte
und was es auch in anderen Ländern gibt.
Und da lag dann erst mal der Verdacht nahe, naja das ist halt total unpolitisch, die Leute fliehen sich in den Konsum.
Und wie Sie sagen, es hat aber eben auch was oppositionelles, weil man damit auch ganz viel ausdrücken kann.
Und gerade, es ist dieses Private, aber das Private ist sehr sehr sichtbar geworden, weil das Private fand nicht in den eigenen vier Wänden statt
und die eigenen vier Wände sind sonst in muslimischen Kulturen und Gesellschaften sehr wichtig und auch dann die Tür zuzumachen,
aber es ist ja sehr viel nach außen getragen worden, also sei es, dass die Leute mit ihrem Handy gezeigt haben,
dass sie da bestimmte Anhänger dran haben, einen kleinen Koran in Miniatur oder einen Bildschirmhintergrund,
der dann auch irgendein islamisches Motiv gezeigt hat und dadurch sehr klar kommuniziert haben nach außen, wo sie sich selber verorten
oder wie sie auch wahrgenommen werden wollen.
Also ich glaube, ich habe das Wort oppositionell gar nicht in den Mund genommen.
Ach so.
Ich habe es auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so gemeint.
Ich habe nur einfach festgestellt, dass, wenn man jetzt sozusagen auf die islamische Gesellschaft schaut und eben versucht nachzuvollziehen,
was so die primären einflussgebenden Faktoren von allen Seiten sind, dass ich dann eben hier auf der einen Seite eben die doch starke religiöse Definition
der Gesellschaft auf Basis von Koran, Ritualen, Althergebrachtem, Vorschriften, Versen, was auch immer, hat,
auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch die Realität der politischen Kultur, also gerade der politische Islam,
der dann über den Iran und auch in anderen Ländern stark über die Gesellschaften hereingebrochen ist
und dann als neues Spannungsfeld im Prinzip ja auch so auch die Moderne,
also die globale Kultur, die Welt, die einfach über alle Grenzen hinweg kommuniziert, die auf uns ja einen Einfluss hat.
Man muss sich ja nur vorstellen, was in Deutschland passiert ist nach dem Krieg durch den amerikanischen westlichen Einfluss,
das hat ja hier auch Sprache verändert, die Warenwelt, die Konsumrealitäten, auch die moralischen Vorstellungen natürlich beeinflusst.
Und das ist ja etwas, wo jetzt mit einer gewissen Verzögerung auch der arabische Raum eben auch versucht, seine Antwort zu finden auf diesen Einfluss,
im Spannungsfeld eben mit diesem starken Einfluss des Islam einfach als Religion und auch für die allgemeine Kultur doch auch sehr definitionsmächtigen Wesen.
Ja. Diese Auseinandersetzung mit der neuen Warenwelt ist tatsächlich oder dieses Feld dieser neuen Warenwelt ist tatsächlich da ein Ort,
wo das ausgetragen werden kann, wie man eigentlich mit bestimmten Einflüssen oder auch Ansprüchen von außen umgeht.
Beispielsweise gibt es ein Feld, was mich sehr fasziniert hat zwischendurch, nämlich Markenprodukte werden gefälscht in weiten Teilen dieser Regionen
sowie auch in, weiß ich nicht, Mexiko oder China, aber in Syrien und im Libanon sind mir irgendwann Markenprodukte begegnet,
die die Insignien großer französischer Designer trugen, die aber eindeutig nicht von diesen hergestellt worden waren,
auch nicht mal entworfen waren in ähnlicher Art, sondern es war ein islamisches Gewand, auf dem plötzlich dieses Chanel-Zeichen sehr groß drauf war.
Das heißt, das ist ja eine ziemlich kreative Art damit umzugehen und sich da etwas anzueignen und so auch sich nicht überrennen zu lassen
oder dominieren zu lassen, sondern eben eine eigene Antwort oder eine eigene Synthese eigentlich zu finden.
Mit dem, dass der Islam so viele Vorgaben macht, das ist ein bisschen ein schwieriger Punkt, weil das stimmt für manche Lebenspraktiken
oder für manche Orientierungen im Islam und kann man aber so allgemein in der Schärfe eigentlich auch nicht sagen, will ich nur nochmal anmerken.
Natürlich gibt es so Vorgaben wie das Gebet und das ist für manche Leute schwer vorstellbar, dass sie fünfmal am Tag da etwas tun sollen,
was ihren Alltag unterbricht.
Wenn jemand jetzt aber seine neue Meditations-App hat, die im Büro kurz ping macht, damit man mal innehält und den Regeln prasseln hört als Entspannung,
dann ist das im Grunde was ganz ähnliches so.
Also man muss das nicht immer nur als Reglementierung und als Einschränkung oder so sehen.
Habe ich das gesagt?
Nein, aber war ich mir nicht so sicher.
Und da das oft so was ist, was so mitschwingt, war mir das ein Anliegen, das gerade nochmal zu sagen.
Okay. Ich habe es nicht unbedingt jetzt so gemeint, dass es zwangsläufig, also wir würden es vielleicht als Einschränkung empfinden in der Außenbetrachtung.
Ja.
Aber ich habe halt genau diesen Eindruck nicht unbedingt, weil dafür ist es ja dann einfach, es ist halt einfach ein anderer Deal, glaube ich.
Was islamische Gesellschaften machen mit dieser Religion ist ein anderes Selbstverständnis, was uns teilweise halt in unserer säkularen Realität
dann sozusagen als Einflussnahme, ungewünschte Einflussnahme vorkommt, ist dort halt eigentlich auch vollkommen normal
und in gewisser Hinsicht auch eingepreist.
Und das, was wir vielleicht so als individuelle Freiheit empfinden, heißt ja nicht, dass es dort nicht stattfindet, es sucht sich bloß einen anderen Ausdruck
und hat andere Katalysatoren, um sich umzusetzen.
Und wenn ich das richtig verstehe ist ja jetzt Ihre Forschung oder speziell eben auch das, was im Rahmen der Dissertation untersucht wurde,
eben dieser konkrete Ausdruck der Moderne in diese neuen Konsumlandschaft, die ja im Prinzip auch für den arabischen Raum was,
naja neu ist vielleicht ein bisschen weit gemacht, aber etwas ist, was sich stark verändert hat in den letzten Jahren.
Genau, so mit den 90ern oder in den 90ern angefangen hat und dann je nachdem, weiß ich nicht, in einer Gesellschaft wie Malaysia,
die sehr marktorientiert ist, früher, in einem Land wie Syrien, was lange abgeschottet war von bestimmten Markteinflüssen, später.
Genau, aber es ist etwas neues, kann man noch so sagen.
Ja, ich meine, Satellitenfernsehen auf der einen Seite und das Internet, denke ich mal, waren hier einfach extreme Faktoren.
Ja.
Wie allgemein ist denn diese Betrachtung?
Also gibt es da extrem große Unterschiede in den einzelnen arabischen Ländern oder kann man das alles über einen Kamm scheren?
Die Antwort liegt nahe, nein.
Nein, kann man nicht.
Also ich habe mir Syrien und Libanon und die Türkei relativ genau angeschaut und gerade zum Beispiel Libanon und Syrien, obwohl Nachbarländer,
unterscheiden sich schon so groß, weil die Konstellation so anders ist.
Also im Libanon gibt es den Konfessionalismus, das heißt, da gibt es viel größere Rivalität zwischen den religiösen Gruppierungen
und eine viel größere Praxis noch der Sichtbarmachung und des nach außen Zeigens.
Wo stehe ich, es ist viel stärker segregiert nach Vierteln in der Stadt und so weiter und da haben Accessoires oder Anhänger,
die man im Auto oder Aufkleber, die man am Auto hat, die haben nochmal eine ganz andere Funktion in Syrien.
Das heißt, man muss sich immer genau angucken, wie ist eigentlich die Konstellation vor Ort.
Und spielt wieder eben die Politik eine Rolle, aber genauso auch die religiösen Gruppen, die dort sind.
Oder dass der Libanon noch viel stärker französisch geprägt ist, das heißt, da gibt es einen stärkeren französischen Einfluss.
Es gab auch in Syrien ein französisches Protektorat, aber diese Nähe wurde nicht so aufrechterhalten
und in Libanon ist die Verbindung zu Frankreich einfach lebendig und dementsprechend sind da auch ganz andere Güter vorhanden.
Das ist die eine Seite, also lokal sehr unterschiedlich.
Die andere ist, dass es durch die globale Warenströme ein und dasselbe Ding made in China in Pakistan, in Großbritannien, in Libanon und im Jemen gibt,
aber es hat ja nicht überall die gleiche Bedeutung, weil es überall in einen anderen Kontext gestellt wird von den Menschen, die es verwenden,
aber auch schon allein es gibt ja ein Set an Objekten, die in dieser Gesellschaft vorhanden sind, an Dingen, an Waren
und dann kommt plötzlich etwas neues und das muss sich da ja eingruppieren, also es steht sozusagen in einem Geflecht
und hat dementsprechend schon eine andere Bedeutung und spricht bei den Leuten durch ihre Vorprägung,
ästhetische Vorprägung, religiöse Vorprägung, wie auch immer, einfach andere Dinge an.
Und das ist das, was mich eigentlich interessiert hat, dass ich dachte, es kann ja …
ich habe Objekte aus Syrien gehabt, zum Beispiel gibt es da das zweischneidige Schwert, der Dhū I-faqār, so vorne die Spitze ist gespalten,
hat eine enge Verbindung zu den Schiiten, aber auch zu den Aleviten, das führt jetzt alles ein bisschen weiter,
aber Punkt ist, dass ich diese Objekte hatte, als ich aus der Forschung zurückkam und nicht wusste, was ich damit machen soll.
Und dann habe ich mir die entsprechenden Enzyklopädien angeschaut, die sonst immer Rat wissen und höchst anerkannt sind
und da stand nichts drin, mit dem ich etwas richtig anfangen konnte.
Und dann dachte ich, das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein, dass es Objekte gibt, die das Leben vieler vieler Menschen prägen.
Wenn Sie durch Neukölln laufen, werden Sie immer wieder Jugendliche sehen, die dieses Schwert auch wirklich in ziemlich großen Größen,
manchmal 15 cm groß oder so als Kette tragen, aber wir eigentlich gar nicht so genau wissen, was das bedeutet für diese Menschen.
Und dann, dass das eben nochmal je nach Land ganz unterschiedlich ist.
Und dann dachte ich, es muss doch einen Weg geben, sich darüber auszutauschen und da Wissen zu generieren,
was noch gar nicht in der Enzyklopädie stehen kann, weil eine Enzyklopädie einen gewissen Vorlauf braucht,
bis ein neuer Artikel überhaupt aufgenommen werden kann und da braucht es doch irgendwie Möglichkeiten sich dadrüber auszutauschen.
Und gab es aber nicht?
Gab es nicht, nein.
Aber es muss ja einen kulturellen Code geben, der jetzt sozusagen diesem Schwert irgendeine Bedeutung zubilligt.
Oder ist das einfach nur so ein kulturelles Phänomen, dass es sich quasi mimetisch einfach durch Kopie seinen Platz überhaupt erst schafft,
so wie wir es ja im Internet auch sehen.
Man sieht irgendwas, man mag das aus welchen Gründen auch immer, andere tun es ähnlich, auf einmal ist es überall,
dadurch verstärkt es sich noch weiter, hatte vorher vielleicht gar keine Bedeutung, sondern erhält quasi im Nachhinein seine Bedeutung,
durch die Leute, die es tragen, in welchem Kontext sie es tragen etc..
Genau, und das ist die Kunst, es zurückzuführen einerseits auf seine vielleicht ursprüngliche Bedeutung,
da fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, es taucht immer mal wieder ein Schiff auf, ein Schiff als Koranständer, ein Schiff auf Plakaten
mit islamischem Kontext oder Kalligrafien, die die Form von Schiffen annehmen so.
Und da habe ich dann vor Ort Leute gefragt, okay was hat es mit diesem Schiff auf sich?
Ja, das ist eine Mode, ach Schiff ist schön.
Also so haben die Leute mir gesagt.
Ich dachte, ahja okay Schiff, ja gut, dann ist das so wie das Einhorn, ist jetzt halt das Schiff.
Und ich dachte, aber irgendwie kann es ja auch nicht ganz sein, dass es …
… nur das ist.
Und das Schiff hat eine Bedeutung im Koran, so wie es im Christentum auch das Schiff als Symbol gibt
und ist, glaube ich, ein Symbol für die Fürsorge Gottes.
Das heißt, da verbreitet sich etwas eigenständig, wo die Leute vielleicht gar nicht wissen, wo es eigentlich herkommt
und es ist auch die Frage, spielt das überhaupt eine Rolle, ist das wichtig, wo es herkommt?
Und bringt mich dann als Forschende in eine schwierige Situation, weil wer bin ich, denen jetzt zu sagen,
ja übrigens es steht aber im Koran, es ist nicht einfach nur eine Mode.
Wo ist dann der …
Also muss ich das, darf ich das, warum tue ich das überhaupt?
Was für Erkenntnisse gewinnen wir daraus?
Und vielleicht beim Schiff jetzt keine großen, weil es einfach nur ein Objekt ist, was im Wohnzimmer steht mit irgendwelchen Glitzersteinchen verziert.
Aber in anderen Fällen, wie bei diesem zweischneidigen Schwert, ist die Frage vielleicht relevanter und da kann ich gar keine befriedigende Antwort geben.
Weil ich mich dann in der Tiefe nicht mehr damit beschäftigt habe.
Aber das ist natürlich ein Symbol, was auch eine gewisse Gewaltkonnotation hat, also tatsächlich dieses Schwert ist gespalten,
weil man damit die Augen piksen kann.
Und dann kann man sagen, ja gut, wenn das vor alle
junge Männer tragen, dann hat das eine Verbindung zu so einem männlichen Pubertätsgehabe meinetwegen und ist halt cool.
So wie vielleicht cool ist, dass eine Zeit lang, weiß nicht, als ich so in der Pubertät war, gab es diese Rasier…
Nein, nicht die Rasierklingen, diese Marken, die amerikanische Soldaten mit ihrem Namen drauf haben,
die gab es plötzlich überall und die haben Leute so getragen, was ja auch, wenn man sich plötzlich zu so einer Armee zuordnen will.
Stimmt, so einen militärischen Duktus …
Ja.
… zu unterstützen.
Und das ist dann im Kontext von Gesellschaften, die generell, wo Gewalt ein großes Problem ist, ist das natürlich zu beachten.
Ein zweischneidiges Schwert ist sozusagen ein zweischneidiges Schwert.
Ja, genau.
Ich meine, es ist ganz interessant, also wenn man jetzt nachweisen würde, ja okay ihr benutzt jetzt ein Symbol,
ihr wisst eigentlich gar nicht warum ihr es benutzt und im Koran findet sich das vielleicht auch, hat da irgendeine Bedeutung,
dass es dort auch mal eine Bedeutung gehabt hat, war ja dann auch mal irgendwann mal wahrscheinlich eine Mode,
die dann überhaupt dazu geführt hat, dass es in diesen Schriften so Einzug gehalten hat und das ästhetische Empfinden hat sich ja dann in gewisser Hinsicht
vielleicht auch über all diese Zeit nicht so nennenswert geändert, also diese Dinge werden ja dann unbewusst auch immer mitgetragen,
etwas, was positive Konnotation hat, verliert die ja nicht erst mal so ohne weiteres.
Auch wir haben ja irgendwie mit bestimmten Objekten einfach immer eine bestimmte Verbindung.
Das mag sich aktualisieren, aber es kann sich dann eben auch lange halten und dann stehen ja so Dinge auch einfach bei uns herum.
Und wenn man fragt, warum, naja ist halt schön so, weil das eben auch akzeptiert ist, dass es so schön ist.
Aber was hat sich denn jetzt geändert?
Also wir haben es mit Gesellschaften zu tun, also der arabische Raum ist ja nun wirklich alles andere als einheitlich.
Trotzdem gibt es natürlich verbindendes Element durch Sprache und Religion und natürlich auch die Geschichte, die fest miteinander verwoben ist.
Jetzt kommt die Moderne daher und sagt, okay alles klar, ab jetzt gibt es hier Westeinfluss, asiatischen Einfluss, einfach einen globalen Einfluss.
Sowohl durch die Präsenz kultureller Objekte.
Jeder weiß, was Amerikaner irgendwie cool finden so.
Man kann nicht mit allem immer was anfangen, aber man kennt es eben zumindest auf der einen Seite.
Auf der anderen Seite wird man ja auch mit Dingen konfrontiert, die vielleicht eben dem moralischen Gerüst, was derzeit vorherrscht stark widerspricht.
Was weiß ich, Nacktheit etc., Wortwahl, Dinge, wie man sich berührt oder nicht berührt, ich weiß es im Einzelnen nicht,
was jetzt vor allem im arabischen Raum auf wenig Gegenliebe stößt zunächst einmal.
Und das muss ja in irgendeiner Form verarbeitet werden.
Was drückt sich jetzt in dieser Warenwelt aus, die man dort sieht?
Was kann man daraus lesen?
Welche Ästhetik wird hier angestrebt?
Ist die mehr eine Art und Weise mit der Moderne klarzukommen oder ist das sozusagen eine Verheiratung mit dem Alten
oder kann man das gar nicht voneinander treffen?
Ja, das kann man nicht gut voneinander trennen in Teilen.
Ja, also ich würde gleich gern nochmal zur, weil das Ganze findet vor dem Hintergrund der islamischen Kunst statt
oder unserem Begriff, wir haben dafür den Begriff islamische Kunst gefunden.
Das ist quasi der Symbolpool, der Hintergrund, vor dem das Ganze stattfindet, dazu können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal kommen.
Aber was mir jetzt so spontan gerade noch kam war, Aushandlungsprozesse oder Moderne und was stößt auf Gegenliebe oder nicht.
Ein Objekt, was prominent war in meiner Forschung, war Verpackungen von so einem Planschbecken.
Viele Leute in Syrien oder anderen Ländern haben diese Häuser mit Innenhöfen, in die so kleine Planschbecken gestellt werden, wenn es heiß ist.
Und auf diesen Verpackungen war eben eine Mutter in Bikini, die Kinder und das Planschbecken.
Und dann wurden mit Edding die Mütter geschwärzt.
Mal nur Brust und Oberkörper, mal haben die plötzlich so eine Abaja, also so ein verhüllendes Gewandt angehabt.
Manchmal sah man nur die Augen, manchmal das Gesicht und das hatte offensichtlich jemand so gemacht mit der Hand.
Das gleiche ist mir dann in Saudi-Arabien nochmal begegnet, wo klar wurde, ahja okay, da kommt also ein Produkt von außen,
war auch made in China, was auch gerne verwendet wird vor Ort, aber man ist nicht damit einverstanden, wie das präsentiert wird,
also greift man ein, passt das irgendwie an an den lokalen Kontext, man kann auch sagen, man zensiert, so wie auch Sachen in Zeitschriften,
in westlichen Zeitschriften vielleicht geschwärzt wurden oder so, gleichzeitig ist Syrien bekannt gewesen vor dem Krieg für seine Reizwäsche.
Also Leute aus dem Golf sind nach Syrien gefahren, um Reizwäsche zu kaufen und in den Märkten, also im Basar, im Suq,
wenn man da durch die Gänge ging, hingen überall solche mit Pailletten bestickten Anzüge mit sehr eindeutigen Schnitten, sagen wir mal,
da gab es irgendwelche Tangas mit Knöpfen, wo dann Musik kam, wenn man draufdrückte und so.
Also das ist offensichtlich ein sehr verspieltes Verhältnis zur Sexualität und da hatte niemand ein Problem damit, dass das da hing
und das auch kleine Kinder gesehen haben, aber es war eben nicht am Körper.
Das macht den Unterschied?
Das macht den Unterschied, das ist der Kontext, wann kann ich etwas zeigen und wann nicht.
Und ich kann es, so wie ich eine figürliche Darstellung nicht im Gebetsraum haben kann, kann ich eben Reizwäsche plus Frau nicht im öffentlichen Raum haben.
Reizwäsche alleine aber schon.
Wo hier vielleicht eher beim Beate Uhse Shop die Leute so ein bisschen beschämt vorbeigehen.
Und ja.
Also was sehen wir jetzt konkret in der Warenwelt?
Wir sehen einmal Dinge, die uns nicht besonders überraschen vielleicht, das ist der Felsendom in Jerusalem, der eine hohe religiöse,
aber auch politische Bedeutung hat.
Wir sehen die Kaaba, also diesen schwarzen Würfel, wir sehen islamische Kalligrafien, aber was neu ist oder anders ist,
dass immer mehr Bilder, also Fotografien vor allem, auftauchen und dass das eine gewisse Reibung erzeugt, sagen wir mal, zu dem,
was eigentlich bis dato so als Pool der islamischen Kunst oder islamischen Ästhetik galt.
Islamische Kunst, auch ein nicht ganz einfacher Begriff, weil es impliziert, dass es auch wieder eine religiös begründete Kunst ist, meint aber eigentlich Kunst,
die in Regionen entstanden ist, die lange unter muslimischer Herrschaft waren oder starken islamischen Einfluss hatten.
Und da ist ganz wichtig Kalligrafie, weil eben die arabische Schrift, die arabische Sprache heilig ist
und es ist so, schon allein Dinge zu schreiben, Koranzitate zu schreiben, ist ein Akt des …
Wie beten.
Genau, es ist meditativ, es hat was von Beten, es ist gottgefällig, das zu tun.
Die Betrachtung von Kalligrafien eröffnet ein Begegnungsmoment mit dem Göttlichen.
Aus dieser besonderen Stellung der Schrift hat sich, man kann nicht sagen was zuerst, aber hat sich eine besondere Bedeutung auch der Ornamentik entwickelt.
Die arabische Schrift besteht vor allem aus Linien, diese Linien können relativ weit gedehnt und gezogen werden.
Das heißt, man ist ziemlich frei damit, wie man Buchstaben arrangiert und dadurch ist der Übergang von Schrift zu Ornament sehr fließend.
Und wenn man sich islamische Architektur anguckt mit diesen vielen Fliesen und Ausmalungen, das sind eben oft so grafische Muster
und man muss zweimal schauen, um zu sehen, aha in dieser Ecke steht aber Mohammed, sieht man aber fast gar nicht,
weil es eingebunden ist in so ein florales Ornament.
Es ist sozusagen versteckt, manchmal ist es auch ganz offensichtlich.
So, aber dieses die Linie ist wichtig, das Grafische ist wichtig, es gibt florale Motive, aber eben keine oder ganz ganz selten mal so figürliche Darstellungen,
dann aber auch nicht in der Moschee, so das sind so ein bisschen die Eckdaten vielleicht.
Und dann gibt es eben plötzlich ein großes Warenangebot, was auch viel konsumiert wird und da haben die Leute das gerne,
wenn auf dem Poster, was sie in ihrem Geschäft aufhängen neben der islamischen Kalligrafie, dass da plötzlich betende Kinder gezeigt werden,
die Rosen zu ihren Füßen haben und die Hände halt so zum Gebet hinhalten und dann gibt es eben auch wieder ein Bild von der Kaaba,
aber es gibt eben diese fotorealistisch oder fotografierten Kinder meinetwegen.
Und das ist neu?
Das ist neu, also dass plötzlich das Bild so eine große Bedeutung bekommen hat.
Kann man auch gleichzeitig sagen, ist nicht verwunderlich, wie bei uns hat das Bild auch nochmal eine ganz schon im vergangenen Jahrhundert,
aber jetzt noch mal mehr mit, was weiß ich, muss man jetzt nicht alles, also Memes oder Instagram oder alles, aufzählen,
aber das Bild nochmal eine ganz andere Bedeutung bekommen und hat sich nochmal anders auch zur Bedeutung der Schrift positioniert.
Das ist eben dort auch geschehen vor dem Hintergrund, dass aber eigentlich Bilder eine geringere Bedeutung, eine weitaus geringere Bedeutung
in der islamischen Kunst haben und in der westlichen Wahrnehmung oft davon ausgegangen wird, dass es doch eigentlich ein Bilderverbot gibt,
ist es eben interessant, sich das anzuschauen.
Kann man es jetzt nur an Bildern festmachen, dass Dinge sich geändert haben?
Nein, dazu kommen dann natürlich so was, und da freut sich das kapitalistische System, dass es plötzlich eine neue Quelle von Innovationen gefunden hat.
Also wenn dieses Beispiel mit dem Zahnreinigungshölzchen vorhin, ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass ein Muslime irgendwo gesagt hat,
ja, also ich finde das ja gut, aber ich möchte mir die Zähne lieber mit einer Zahnbürste putzen und hat dann,
ja vielleicht hat er dann diese Zahnpasta mit dem Extrakt erfunden, aber eigentlich halte ich es für wahrscheinlicher,
dass es eben ein Austauschprozess ist, aber der doch sehr stark von diesem kapitalistischen Motor angetrieben wird.
Da ist halt eine Möglichkeit …
… Nischen zu finden.
… ja da kann man neue Nischen finden und diese Nischen sind gigantisch.
Weil es sind nicht nur die Produkte, zum Beispiel in Deutschland gab es dann auch plötzlich Halāl Gummibären, weil sich verbreitet hat,
dass in Haribo Schweinegelatine ist und das wird ausdifferenziert bis ins letzte Eckchen.
Dann gibt es Pinsel zum Malen, also für Kunst, die dann eben gerade keine Schweineborsten haben und das wird dann eben auch als halāl verbreitet.
Oder Kosmetik, die nochmal genau geprüft wird, ob da nicht auch irgendwelche Derivate sind.
Das wird also ganz ganz weit geführt.
So ein bisschen wie Veganismus sich eigentlich auch mittlerweile so eine komplett eigene Warenwelt erschließt …
Ja.
… sich nicht immer unbedingt direkt mit Ernährung zu tun hat.
Und das ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil was diese beiden Trends, sage ich mal, verbindet, ist, dass dahinter steht ja eine Lebensauffassung
oder eine Selbstpositionierung zur Welt, die eigentlich ganzheitlich ist.
Da geht es nicht nur darum, was darf ich essen oder was darf ich nicht essen, sondern wie ich die Welt sehe, was ich für richtig halte, für moralisch verwerflich,
das durchzieht die Form, wie ich Beziehung lebe, wie ich Kinder erziehe, welche Schule ich aussuche, welche Filme ich sehe, was ich für Schuhe anziehe,
was ich esse, wohin ich in den Urlaub fahre und wie lange.
Also das betrifft eigentlich alles.
Und genauso gibt es ja, jetzt schon länger, aber gibt es so Ferienressorts, wo geschlechtergetrennte Pools sind
oder wo gesagt wird, da gibt es eben gar keinen Alkohol, da muss niemand die Befürchtung haben, dass da Alkohol ausgeschenkt wird.
Und das heißt, man schafft ein Angebot auch an Dienstleistungen und diese Dienstleistung das ist definitiv auch etwas neues.
Also islamische Banken waren eine Zeit lang groß im Gespräch, aber das islamische Versicherungswesen, islamische Reisen.
Habe ich neulich zufällig gesehen, islamische Grußkarten, da kann man dann so ein Set bestellen und einen Einband für den Mutterpass,
der dann noch so eine Segensformel drauf hat.
Also es wird ausdefiniert für jeglichen Bereich, den man sich eigentlich so vorstellen kann.
Mir fällt gerade ein, dass es ja eigentlich einen ähnlichen Trend auch in Israel gibt.
Der jüdische Glauben ist ja auch nicht gerade schwach, was so Regeln und Riten betrifft, also allein der Tanz, der da mit dem Sabbat immer gemacht wird,
was man da dann halt alles irgendwie nicht tun kann, aber wenn man es dann irgendwie trotzdem tun will, sucht man sich sozusagen da auch wieder so eine interessante Produktnische.
Ich stecke da jetzt nicht so tief drin, ich erinnere mich nur schwach daran, dass es so ein bisschen so einen ähnlichen Charakter hat,
dass man also auch hier versucht, die Moderne mit der Religion in Einklang zu bringen und in gewisser Hinsicht war ja Israel dann auch noch ein bisschen eher dran,
weil sie sich ja selbst sehr viel mehr westlich orientiert haben.
Genau, die Parallele besteht auf jeden Fall und ist interessant, da habe ich mich nie tiefer mit beschäftigt, aber die lädt ein zum Vergleich.
Auch so koscher ist ja dann sozusagen im Prinzip auch nochmal genauso.
Hat einen ähnlichen starken Korpus an Verboten und Geboten.
Vielleicht wäre das nochmal ein Forschungsfeld.
Da gehen einem die Themen sicherlich auch nicht aus.
Um nochmal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was irgendwie …
Weil ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen die Erwartungshaltung, vielleicht ist die falsch, dass eben durch diese ganzen Zwänge und Verflechtungen,
über die wir jetzt schon gesprochen haben, in der arabischen Warenwelt Dinge entstehen, die ich mir so nicht vorstellen kann
oder zumindest irgendwie irgendeine Absurdität auf mich und andere ausstrahlen, wenn ich sie jetzt sehe, ich kenne sie aber halt nicht.
Gibt es da irgendwie was oder übertreibe ich jetzt schon?
Was ganz …
Also es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt absurd sein, aber was ist, also ich meine, immer wenn man ins Ausland fährt und ich war jetzt noch nicht so oft in arabischen Ländern,
hier und da klar irgendwas fällt einem immer auf, wo man sich denkt so, oh so etwas habe ich noch nie gesehen
oder das hat jetzt irgendwie eine Dimension oder das übertreibt oder untertreibt in irgendeiner Form, wie das sozusagen aus meinem kulturellen Kontext mir so nicht bekannt ist
und das findet man ja dann immer am interessantesten.
Worauf könnte ich denn stoßen, wenn ich jetzt durch ein arabisches Kaufhaus laufe?
Ist irgendwas anders, ist irgendwie das Küchengeschirr anders, werden Dinge irgendwie anders verpackt, gibt es irgendwie eine andere Schilderwelt,
sind Spielzeuge was anderes, was könnte mir da so widerfahren?
Also nehmen wir dieses Szenario Kaufhaus.
Ja.
Kommt darauf an, wann Sie hingehen.
Mag sein, dass es zum Beispiel – das gilt jetzt nur für bestimmte Länder – dass Gebetszeit ist, dann wird kurz eine Durchsage gemacht, Pause gemacht.
Das habe ich so in Saudi-Arabien erlebt.
Da darf man nichts kaufen dann?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, ob wirklich alle Geschäfte geschlossen haben.
Gibt es aber auf jeden Fall.
Ja, und in Syrien und Libanon kenne ich das, dass so einzelne Händler dann so ein Schild ins Fenster hängen, die sind dann besonders beflissen,
da soll man auch sehen, okay die gehen jetzt beten, andere gehen einfach beten und hängen kein Schild rein.
Da ist es völlig klar, oder habe ich jetzt auch in Marokko gesehen, da werden halt so Besenstile so vor dem Eingang gekreuzt
und dann geht da auch niemand rein und stiehlt auch nichts.
Dann würden Sie übers Jahr verteilt bestimmte Dinge sehen.
Also zum Beispiel dass so was wie der Valentinstag oder der Muttertag ganz stark angepriesen wird mit entsprechenden Produkten,
die aber oft dann auch einen religiösen Bezug haben oder mit islamischen Grußformeln, Segensformeln verbunden werden.
Das ist also auch so eine Melange der Kulturen?
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ja.
Eine Melange und manchmal ist das so fließend.
Zum Beispiel das Herz taucht relativ häufig auf.
Das Herz, da ist es auch an der Wand, aber das Herz ist jetzt kein islamisches Symbol, wird aber ganz oft mit der Liebe zu Mohammed und der Gottesliebe verknüpft.
Und passt so wunderbar zum Valentinstag, der dann nochmal ein neues Marktfeld eröffnet.
Dann beim Spielzeug zum Beispiel eben dieses Gebetsset in rosa.
Dann gibt es ganz viele Videospiele, die oft so, bin ich nicht auf dem neuesten Stand, aber die sich dann mit der islamischen Geschichte beschäftigen
und manchmal auch mit der Besatzung in Palästina oder so, aber müssen gar nicht unbedingt so politisch sein
und wo dann so ein spielerischer Umgang gefunden werden soll für die Vermittlung des Glaubens.
Und da gibt es so kleine Lerncomputer, da hatte ich mal so dieses erste MacBook, was ganz rund und bunt war.
Das iBook.
Genau, das gab es dann, nur dass, wenn man dann auf die Tasten gedrückt hat, dann wurden Koransuren vorgespielt.
Oder gesagt, wie der Gebetsablauf ist, also wie die Bewegungsfolge ist.
Und dieser Markt zum Beispiel für Kinder, der Markt der Vermittlung, der ist gigantisch.
Und ich glaube, so Bücher gab es schon lange, so kleine Heftchen oder so, aber da gibt es plötzlich ganz viele,
die mit so einer Comicästhetik arbeiten.
Dann denkt man, ach ja okay, das ist auch wieder eine Melange, die Kinder haben Superman-Comics gelesen, jetzt wollen Sie Comics auch,
oder damit macht man ihnen das schmackhaft, aber das hat auch wieder was mit so Prinzipien der Darstellung in der islamischen Kunst zu tun,
weil es eben dieses flächige oft hat und gar nicht darauf angelegt ist, so Gesichter natürlich wiederzugeben,
sondern sie sind im Grunde vereinfacht und abstrahiert und damit passen sie sehr gut auch in eine Auffassung von Islam, die eher streng ist.
Und man sagt, man soll sich nicht anmaßen, den Schöpfungsakt Gottes auf dem Papier nachzuahmen,
indem man so ein besonders originelles, originäres Bild schafft.
Da gibt es dann mit jeder technischen Neuerung was neues.
Dann gab es DVDs, erst gab es Kassetten, dann gab es DVDs, jetzt gibt es irgendwelche Videotutorials.
In Großbritannien gibt es einen Teddybären, der auch Koransuren spricht, den habe ich jetzt in arabischen Ländern nicht so gesehen.
Ja, also ich glaube, Kinder sind lukrativ so wie auch hier, ist aber auch nicht in allen Ländern gleich.
In der Türkei gibt es zum Beispiel ganz wenig für Kinder in dieser Hinsicht.
Also man kann sagen, ich höre jetzt so ein bisschen raus, das hat dann immer viel mit Religion und mit diesem religiösen Grundverhalten zu tun?
Genau, es gibt immer eine Interaktion mit dem religiösen und manchmal entsteht dann so in der Mischung was neues.
Manchmal wird es nur angereichert, manchmal wird es abgewandelt, da wo es vielleicht anstößig wäre, wenn man es einfach so eins zu eins übernehmen würde.
Was ganz skurriles kann ich Ihnen gar nicht so nennen.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht unbedingt auf was skurriles, sondern vielleicht einfach nur auf was anderes.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob es aber auch irgendetwas gibt, was jetzt mal jenseits von diesem Bezug zur Religion und dem religiösen Verhalten
in irgendeiner Form dort zu finden ist, was wir sozusagen so gar nicht haben.
Ich meine, Asien ist voll mit solchen Dingen und ist ja auch ganz fleißig dabei, das dann wieder hier hineinzuimportieren,
wie ja auch generell die asiatische Kultur, also speziell die japanische, stückweit sicherlich auch so der chinesische Raum,
ganz gut da drin ist, auch selber so zu einer Kulturexportregion zu werden.
Also dass sozusagen nicht nur die Waren, die wir haben wollen, weil wir sie schon kennen und brauchen, aber auch gerne mal billiger haben möchten,
dass die zu uns kommen, sondern dass wir im zunehmende Maße auch eben kulturell Bekanntschaft mache.
So wie Mangas aus Japan, die ja mehr nur als ein kleiner Kulturbeitrag sind, sondern die ja stilbildend sind
und einfach auch eine ganz eigene Warenwelt mit sich bringt, die ganzen Figuren und so, das hatten wir ja schon gerade gehört,
das Figürliche und so ist im arabischen Raum noch ein bisschen rückständig.
Gibt es denn irgendwas originär arabisches, was es in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch wieder in den westlichen Kulturraum schaffen könnte,
wenn nicht heute, dann vielleicht in absehbarer Zeit, so was die aktuellen Spitzenreiter arabische Zahlen vielleicht nochmal Konkurrenz machen könnte?
Naja, ich glaube, da gibt es eine Verschiebung, also so wie es schon mal eine Japanfaszination im späten 19./frühen 20. Jahrhundert gab,
gibt es die jetzt vielleicht wieder über diese ganz andere Schiene Mangas.
Also bei uns?
Ja bei uns.
Habe ich den Eindruck, es ist gerade nicht die Zeit für Islam als großer Exportschlager.
Also natürlich gibt es auch viele Konvertiten und so weiter, dass es eine Anziehungskraft hat und gerade der mystische Islam vielleicht,
der so eine ganz eigene Art hat oder so, vielleicht eher, aber es gab ja mal eine ganz ganz große Orientfaszination
und das ist der Ursprung für diese ganzen problematischen Begriffe, die so als orientalistisch bezeichnet werden,
wo es eine riesige Aufarbeitung gegeben hat und nach wie vor gibt.
Was denn für Begriffe?
Naja, alles mit dem Orientailistischen und dann eben, der Orientale ist so und so.
Also auch dieser Topos der Rückständigkeit kommt auch aus dieser Zeit, der aber gleichzeitig immer mit so einer wahnsinnigen Faszination verbunden war,
weil da gab es die Harems, da gab es diese Haremkultur, da gab es die schönen Frauen, da gab es dieses Üppige, dieses sinnlich schwelgende …
Geschichten aus 1001 Nacht.
Und dieses Üppige und Schwelgende und so, das kann man als so durchlaufendes Motiv zwar auch jetzt in der Art wie Waren präsentiert werden
oder auch wie Waren gestaltet werden durchaus wiederfinden, hat aber jetzt meines Wissens keinen großen Einfluss auf die Gesellschaften hier.
Und ich denke, dass das Verhältnis zu allem, zu dem Islam kann man nicht sagen, aber zu allem, was so mit Islam zu tun hat,
ist so schwierig und gestört, dass ich da gerade kein großes Potenzial sehe.
Also Potenzial sehe ich, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es gerade geschehen wird.
Aber es könnte natürlich auch ein echter Brückenschlag sein.
Ja genau, das ist ja mein Anliegen, zu zeigen, erstens die Sachen sind gar nicht so fremd, die sind gar nicht so komisch,
die sind gar nicht, da geht es nicht die ganze Zeit um Verzicht und oh Gott, ich ziehe mich nur schwarz an und sitze in der Ecke und darf nichts,
sondern da gibt es Dinge, die ansprechend sind, die schön sind, die kunstfertig gemacht sind, die hier auch gefallen können.
Oder es gibt eine ganz andere Form, wie man Dinge gestaltet, arrangiert, präsentiert.
Darüber so eine Brücke zu bauen, indem man halt Bilder zeigt, die anders sind als die Bilder, die man sonst so präsentiert bekommt.
Und ich glaube, islamische Kunst hat schon noch diese Brückenwirkung, das sieht man hier, glaube ich, in Berlin auch gerade
mit dem Museum für islamische Kunst und da gibt es natürlich auch ein Interesse, das als Brückenbildungspotenzial zu nutzen.
Und wenn Sie da in das Museum für islamische Kunst gehen und sich die Keramik angucken, Keramik ist ein wichtiges Element in der islamischen Kunst,
Gebrauchskeramik, die aber sehr häufig mit Kalligrafien verziert ist, weil wiederum der Schrift
und den koranischen Versen sozusagen eine Segenskraft innewohnt aus muslimischer Sicht, die Segenskraft Gottes
und die geht in das, was ich in die Schüssel fülle, über.
Und kann dadurch zum Beispiel das Wasser, was ich da einfülle, heilend machen, das ist der Grund, warum es diese vielen Kalligrafien auf Gefäßen gibt, einer der Gründe.
So und da gibt es so Keramik aus Nischapur, fragen Sie mich jetzt nicht, aus dem 12. oder 11. Jahrhundert,
wenn Sie das sich anschauen und dann den momentan Bauhaus-Hype, dann haben die Bauhaus schon gemacht,
als hier noch irgendwelche Holzlöffel geschnitzt wurden.
Und da gibt es eben so ästhetische Prinzipien der Einfachheit und der Klarheit in der Gestaltung,
die eben hier zur Moderne gehören und die da zu einem Zeitpunkt schon verbreitet waren und wichtig waren, als es den Begriff Moderne nicht gab.
Wo ich auch noch so eine Bewegung sehe und ich bin auch immer noch so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach der Rückwirkung auf uns,
die Auseinandersetzung mit Verschleierung ist ja auch ein heißes Thema, nicht nur bei uns, sondern eben vor allem auch zum Beispiel in Saudi-Arabien,
wo das ja sehr stark durchgesetzt wird und wo es ja auch gerade unter Frauen eine extrem starke Gegenbewegung gibt.
Und nicht nur dort, also auch auf verschiedene Bereiche, Iran ist es natürlich auch ähnlich, ich weiß nicht, Iran fällt jetzt so ein bisschen raus,
weil man es ja nicht wirklich als arabischen Raum, aber eben schon als islamischen Raum verstehen muss.
Einerseits gibt es natürlich diesen Protest dagegen, also warum sollen wir uns verschleiern, von den etwas radikaler reagierenden Frauen.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eben aber auch diese Adaption über die Produktwelt, dass man eben neue Designs, neue Arten und Weisen,
Schleier, Kopftücher etc. zu tragen, findet und darüber eben auch einen ganz neuen Modetrend auslöst, der sicherlich in der arabischen Welt
auch schon eine gewisse Bedeutung hat, hier natürlich nur eingeschränkt eben über muslimische Menschen in Europa zu uns kommt.
Oder auch der Burkini, der, glaube ich, eine Erfindung aus …
Aus Australien, glaube ich.
… Australien war, genau, um eben genau diese Adaption muslimischer Realitäten in einem mehrheitlich nicht muslimischen Land vornehmen zu können.
Sind das gute Beispiele?
Der Burkini, ja, der ist auf jeden Fall etwas, wo die Leute erstaunt sind, sagen wir mal.
Welche Leute, alle?
Nein. Naja, sowohl Islamwissenschaftler, als der so auftauchte und man dachte, ahja Wahnsinn als auch eben Leute,
die das einfach sehen und denken, sowas gibt es?
Ist jetzt, finde ich, von der Bademode, die mein Urgroßvater getragen hat, vielleicht gar nicht, von der Kopfbedeckung abgesehen, gar nicht so anders.
Ja, oder auch die Urgroßmutter.
Also ich meine, wenn ich mir so Bilder von 1900 anschaue, wie da so die Bademode war, das ist jetzt vom Burkini nicht so weit entfernt gewesen.
Ja oder die Urgroßmutter.
Genau. Und dahinter ist ja, denke ich, oft einfach das Anliegen, dass jemand Sport machen will, aber bestimmte Vorgaben dafür zu beachten hat.
Und ich meine, dass es auch Leute gibt, also nicht-Muslime, die den gerne tragen, die einfach keine Lust haben, sich so sehr nackig zu zeigen.
Und mit dem Schleier ist das generell natürlich ein sehr weites Feld.
Da ist ganz interessant, dass zum Beispiel aber in einer …
Also man schaut oft dann auf Saudi-Arabien oder den Iran, dass aber zum Beispiel in der Türkei sich ganz stark ablesen ließ,
dass, wenn es nicht erlaubt ist, dann vielmehr das Bedürfnis ja auch sichtbar wird, den für sich zu erobern und den als Zeichen zu benutzen.
Im Iran, wo er eben Zwang ist, werden die Grenzen ausgereizt bis zum geht nicht mehr und noch ein Zentimeter Haaransatz und noch ein Zentimeter Haaransatz.
Genau, da gibt es wahnsinnige Varianzen, wenn man sich die unterschiedlichen Länder anschaut.
Oder in Malaysia habe ich mal so Frauenmagazine gesehen, da gibt es so richtige Hijab-Artists, die dann mit dem Stoff quasi Frisuren bauen.
Dass dann so riesige Blumen entstehen oder dass es so ganz üppig und prächtig wird.
Und da gibt es ja eine wahnsinnige Spielbreite von, Kopftuch soll nur verdecken, aber keine Aufmerksamkeit auf die Person lenken,
bis zu, das werden Formen, so wie sich früher Frauen irgendwelche Schiffe oder so in die Frisur gesteckt haben, also möglichst auffallend,
möglichst bunt, möglichst präsent sein.
Das heißt, hat hier die Mode nochmal eine ganz besondere Bedeutung?
Ja, an der Mode lassen sich eigentlich alle Spielarten muslimischen Lebens ablesen.
Da gibt es alles von beispielsweise Firmen, kann ich auch wieder am Beispiel aus Syrien machen, vor dem Krieg gab es eine Firma,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt, die hatten auch einen Namen, der sich aus der Theologie speiste, Shukr hießen die,
und die haben Kleidung produziert, die nur aus Naturmaterialien hergestellt war, ein riesiges Ding in Syrien,
weil da ganz viel Lurex und Polyester und so angesagt war zu der Zeit, also nur Leinen und Baumwolle, nur Erdtöne, dann entsprechende Vorgaben eingehalten wie,
dass die Knöchel nicht bedeckt sind.
Das machen auch nur Sunniten einer besonderen Ausprägung, dass das für die wichtig ist, die Knöchel nicht zu bedecken,
weil das wiederum auch auf die Prophetentradition zurückgeht, auf einen Hadith, wo gesagt wird, dass solle man lieber nicht tun.
Und da gibt es die Modefotografie, also die Werbebroschüren, die es für diese Firma gab, haben die Models ohne Kopf gezeigt.
Da wurde einfach, da muss man nicht verschleiern oder so, da ist einfach der Kopf nicht da, und das sieht man auch in Neukölln an einigen Läden,
da weiß man gleich, in welcher Liga die sozusagen spielen, weil das dann einfach eine ganz …
da geht es wirklich darum, das ist dann wirklich ein islamischer Laden, das ist kein muslimischer Laden, also ein Laden von einem Muslim,
der irgendwie glaubt und da sein Allah an die Wand hängt, weil es ihn an den guten Glauben erinnert, sondern das ist eine andere Agenda sozusagen.
Und die Mode ist da ein Feld, wo sich alles unterbringen lässt.
Also zum Beispiel im Libanon sehr designaffines Land mit viel Strahlkraft auch wieder für den Golf, also viele Leute mit viel Geld aus dem Golf kommen,
um im Libanon einzukaufen, da gibt es viele Modedesigner, die dann so kimonoartige Gewänder hergestellt haben,
die dann sowohl für Muslime passend waren als aber auch für so ein Boheme-Publikum, was es auch im Libanon gibt,
wo die Tunika sozusagen …
Die Künstlerin, die Tunika getragen hat mit ihrer Hochsteckfrisur und ihren großen Ringen und dem auffälligen Schmuck
und die gleiche Tunika hat eine Muslimin getragen, die in einer ganz anderen gesellschaftlichen Sphäre vielleicht verkehrt hat.
Und da haben sich eben so Entwürfe etabliert, die für verschiedene gesellschaftliche Sphären anschlussfähig sind.
Und dann spielt eben soziale Distinktion eine große Rolle oder eben auch soziale Abstufungen, was es wo gibt,
das kann man schon auch dann ablesen, welche Materialien verwendet werden oder was gerade hipp und angesagt ist.
Jetzt haben Sie ja in Ihrer Forschung auch noch ein spezielles Projekt gestartet, da nennt sich Hawass, was heißt das?
Hawass bedeutet Sinne und das ist deshalb für mich wichtig gewesen oder es heißt deshalb so, weil der Begriff der Ästhetik,
der eben auch im Namen der Plattform drinsteckt, Contemporary Islamic Astethics, sehr viel mit der sinnlichen Wahrnehmung zu tun hat,
was aber in der so populärwissenschaftlichen Verwendung, aber auch oft in der wissenschaftlichen Verwendung zu kurz kommt,
da geht man davon aus, dass Ästhetik eigentlich nur das Schöne betrifft erst mal, nicht unbedingt das Hässliche.
Dann überhaupt so eher Gestaltung und vielleicht noch den Geschmack, aber nichts mehr mit Aisthesis, also der Wahrnehmung, zu tun hat.
Die Wahrnehmung ist aber ganz zentral, weil die unsere Verbindung zur Welt ist und ganz viel mit Erkenntnis zu tun hat.
Also Erkenntnis funktioniert über Wahrnehmung und Wahrnehmung ist ganz aktiv, wenn ich ein Objekt berühre, wenn ich ein Bild anschaue,
wenn ich mich bewege zum Beispiel zu einem religiösen Gesang oder wenn ich eine Gebetskette durch meine Finger gleiten lasse
und die ein bestimmtes Material und die Perlen eine bestimmte Größe haben.
Und deshalb heißt diese Seite so, um diesen Aspekt der Wahrnehmung ein bisschen in den Fokus zu rücken
und weil im Islam oder der Islam eine sehr sinnliche Religion ist.
Also Hawass, muss man dazu sagen, ist dann ein webbasiertes Projekt, quasi eine Exhibition von Alltagsfotos, urbanen Szenen eben auch dieser Produktwelt,
aber auch der typografischen Realität und Ästhetik.
Genau. Es geht um Angewandtes, Alltägliches, eben nicht diesen erhabenen Bereich der Kunst, also da kann auch mal ein Plakat vorkommen,
was vielleicht durchaus künstlerischen Ansprüchen gerecht wird, aber im Grunde geht es um Alltagskultur.
Das Bild steht im Fokus, ist auch auf der, wenn man die Startseite aufruft, ist das eben der Showroom, da sind die Bilder im Fokus.
Auch mit der Idee, eben gewisse Wahrnehmungsverschiebung zu erreichen mit dem, was man eigentlich von bestimmten Gesellschaften so erwartet
und dann zu sehen, ah okay da ist eine Straßenszene, die sieht ja nun ganz anders aus als ich gedacht habe.
Oder, ach was, sieh an, da gibt es auch, weiß nicht, in Marokko tragen die Frauen beispielsweise sind komplett verhüllt zum Teil,
aber tragen die abgefahrendsten Muster darauf.
Also ist eine Farbexplosion, wenn die Frau vorbeigeht.
Dann ist es aber nicht so, es geht nicht nur darum, diese Bilder zu zeigen, sondern es geht darum, diese Bilder miteinander in Beziehung zu setzen
und über diese Beziehungen, die dann entstehen, neue Querverbindungen aufzeigen zu können und dann gemeinsam in einer nicht zwangsläufig
nur akademischen Community die Dinge zu kommentieren, sich Fragen stellen zu können, eben um diese Lücke zu schließen,
die in der Sekundärliteratur oder in den Enzyklopädien oder so was besteht, bei vielen zeitgenössischen Erscheinungen.
Das Projekt ist ja unter anderem vom Stifterverband gefördert, aber auch Wikimedia Deutschland ist hier dabei.
Das ist sozusagen im Programm „Freies Wissen“ gefördert worden.
Was ist jetzt hier sozusagen dieser freie Wissensaspekt und wie soll hier vorgegangen werden?
Na, was es ausmacht und ungewöhnlich macht, ist, dass es eine Lücke schließt.
Also normalerweise ist der Ablauf so, man forscht eben, ich spreche jetzt von qualitativer Forschung, das heißt, man fährt irgendwo hin,
führt Interviews, macht Notizen, filmt, weiß nicht, also es geht nicht um große Datenerhebungen.
Also normalerweise legen die Leute ein Archiv an, dann arbeiten sie ewig lange mit diesen Objekten, sortieren was aus,
wenn es hochkommt, verwendet man 10% dessen was man hat und dann kommt irgendwann ein Artikel rausgepresst
und all das, das dazwischen an Gedankenschritten, an Material, an Ideen gewesen ist, ist nicht sichtbar.
Der Prozess fällt weg.
Der Prozess ist nicht sichtbar.
Und mich interessieren diese Prozesse, mich interessiert, wie verschiedene Techniken und Technologien auf unser Denken einwirken
und wie man mit bestimmten Techniken, sei es Handschrift versus Maschinenschrift oder ebne solchen Plattformen,
wie das sich auf die Art zu Denken und zu Konzipieren auswirkt.
Und es soll ein bisschen die Angst davor nehmen, Gedanken auszusprechen.
Also für mich ist es eine große Erleichterung, sagen zu können, also ich stelle da ein Foto ein und sage, hier das habe ich in Marokko gesehen,
ich weiß eigentlich nicht genau was es ist, ich habe so was ähnliches schon mal in Syrien gesehen, da bedeutet das das und das, vielleicht weiß jemand was.
Also Sie sagten ja gerade, es soll sich nicht nur einer akademischen Öffentlichkeit stellen, aber es soll sich vor allem einer Öffentlichkeit stellen?
Nein, idealerweise wäre das für mich gar nicht vor allem.
Aber natürlich ist das …
Das ist schon ein Ziel?
Es ist eins der Ziele, ja.
Aber da zum Beispiel wie Sie schon gerade sagten, ich interssiere mich sehr für Typografie und die …
Genau, weil arabische Schrift so zentral ist, ist auch wichtig, sich anzugucken, wie die eigentlich geschrieben wird,
gibt es eine ganz eigene Tradition auch und hat zum Beispiel darüber meinen Blick auch auf lateinische Typografie nochmal verändert.
Wir lesen so viel, aber die wenigsten Leute machen sich Gedanken darüber, wie das gesetzt und gestaltet ist, was sie da lesen
und was das eigentlich auch mit der Informationsverarbeitung macht.
Und so interessieren mich dann eben vor allem Sachen, wo islamische Typografie und lateinische Typografie sich begegnen,
also so bilinguale Schilder zum Beispiel.
Und die Grafiker und Webdesigner, mit denen ich die Seite dann gemacht habe, die sind sehr versiert in diesen biskriptualen und bilingualen Gestaltungen
und merke auch, ich habe parallel einen Instagram-Account, wo ich dann manchmal Sachen hochlade, die ich so schnell mit dem Handy mache,
und dass eben gerade diese ganzen typografischen Sachen da durchaus auf großes Interesse stoßen, aber eben zum Beispiel von Gestalterseite.
Und das wäre ein Punkt, wo man sagen kann, ah okay, da gibt es sozusagen was zu holen, also da kann man was sich angucken,
da kann man inspiriert werden und da kann man, man muss ja nicht gleich was lernen, aber man kann wie man japanische Mangas interessant findet
und die was mit der Ästhetik auch hier auf manchen Ebenen gemacht haben, kann man sich da etwas anschauen und sieht plötzlich eine Art
wie etwas gesetzt ist oder wie mit Schrift kreativ umgegangen wird, die vielleicht für hier einen Anstoß bietet.
Wo soll das dann sozusagen auch einen wissenschaftlichen Dialog eröffnen?
Also geht es jetzt auch konkret daran, mit anderen Islamwissenschaftlerinnen gemeinsam jetzt daran zu arbeiten
und auch irgendwie gemeinsame Forschungsergebnisse vielleicht am Ende vorzustellen?
Das wäre natürlich fantastisch, wenn das geschieht.
Also weil ich finde, ein Problem der Wissenschaft ist zumindest für mich persönlich, dass alles so isoliert stattfindet
und der Austausch findet auf einer Konferenz statt und vielleicht über irgendwelche Rezensionen, aber so sehr viel Austausch gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Und wenn sich daraus ergibt, dass man mit jemandem konkret an einem Projekt zusammenarbeiten kann, das fände ich ganz wunderbar.
Genau, angedacht ist eben, zum Beispiel hat mich eine Frau aus den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten angesprochen,
die sammelt Buchcover aus der arabischen Welt.
Und hat gesagt, ich bin hier bei der Bildersuche irgendwie auf deine Sachen gestoßen, kann ich meine Sachen hochladen?
Und dann kann man eben so Archivbestände bündeln und damit ja auch ein Onlinearchiv richtig schaffen, mit dem Leute wieder arbeiten können.
Und das klingt jetzt, also ich wurde dann auch gefragt, ja, aber warum benutzt du denn nicht einfach, was weiß ich, Pinterest
oder warum guckst du nicht bei den Wiki-Commons-Sachen
Weil es da einfach nicht viel gibt.
Da gibt es eine sehr geringe Auswahl.
Also bei Wikimedia gibt es zum Beispiel eine sehr geringe Auswahl und eine schlechte Verschlagwortung.
Und wenn man dann sich so was wie Pinterest oder so anschaut, dann gibt es viel, aber das ist dann eben zum Beispiel oft von …
dann gibt es dann irgendwelche Sachen, diese Wandtattoos waren mal eine Zeit lang modern, dass man sich so Sachen an die Wand klebt,
da gab es dann islamische Kalligrafien, die fotografiert wurden, wie man die an die Wand kleben kann.
Davon gab es dann ganz viele.
Oder irgendwelche Memes mit islamischem Inhalt, das ist ja auch interessant, aber erfüllt nicht diesen Anspruch, ganz gezielt und konzentriert etwas zu sammeln
und sich so einem Thema zu nähern, das sozusagen einzupreisen.
Naja und die kommerziellen Plattformen scheiden natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht aus, weil man nicht weiß, wie der Zugriff darauf geregelt ist.
Ja genau, man weiß auch nicht …
Und sich zukünftig entwickeln wird.
Dann verschwinden halt bestimmte Inhalte wieder.
Von daher geht es da eher darum, erst mal einen Pool von neuen Eindrücken zu sammeln, auf dem dann wissenschaftlich gearbeitet werden kann.
Genau und das dann auch unter offene Lizenz zu stellen, wo ich dachte, dass es viel mehr Gegenwind geben würde,
was aber niemanden von den Wissenschaftlern, mit denen ich bisher gesprochen habe oder bei denen ich es vorgestellt habe, irritiert hat.
Da hätte ich gedacht, da gibt es größere Probleme.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein Anspruch zu sagen, es soll verwendet werden.
Vielleicht ändert sich da langsam was.
Ja.
Dass man einsieht, dass man da mehr von hat, wenn man es so frei gestaltet, als immer in diesem Rattenrennen gegenseitig... voneinander abgetrennt Forschung zu machen,
wo jeder als Erster durchs Ziel kommen möchte.
Genau, das macht auf jeden Fall die Wissenschaft ja auch nicht angenehm und anstrengend dieses kompetetive.
Und an dieser Graduiertenschule Berlin Muslime Cultures and Societies zum Beispiel herrscht eben wirklich ein anderer Geist,
gerade weil die Projekte so heterogen waren.
Also da war dann auch niemand, mit dem man dann direkt konkurrierte, weil die so unterschiedlich waren, dass man nicht fürchten musste,
dass man sich irgendeinen Slot bei der Konferenz wegnimmt.
Aber man hat gemerkt, okay da gibt es zum Beispiel einen Kunsthistoriker und einen Architekten und noch jemanden,
die alle spüren gerade was ähnliches, die beschäftigen sich gerade mit so einer Stimmung vielleicht in der Islamwissenschaft,
ah, mit denen kann man doch was zusammen machen.
Und das ist vielleicht auch die Idee, Leute zusammenzubringen, die eine ähnliche Art haben zu denken und zu forschen.
Wir haben ja auch hier bei Forschergeist schon in zahlreichen Gesprächen immer wieder festgestellt, dass in zunehmendem Maße es geboten ist,
sich interdisziplinär aufzustellen, einfach um der Komplexität der Forschungsgegenstände oder der wissenschaftlichen Herausforderung überhaupt gerecht zu werden
und dass es letztlich auch bereichernd ist, weil man natürlich dann, dadurch dass andere Leute mehr oder weniger im selben Kontext,
aber andere Aspekte, herausarbeiten, man eben natürlich auch eine ganz andere Kompetenz dann noch zur Seite gestellt bekommt,
um überhaupt Dinge vielleicht erst mal zu entdecken und zu verstehen, die man sonst so durch den Fokus auf das eigene Feld so gar nicht gehabt hätte.
Ja, unbedingt ist das so.
Also ja, da sind eigentlich immer die größten Impulse gekommen, wenn ich mit jemandem gesprochen habe, der aus einer ganz anderen Ecke geschaut hat.
Heißt ja gar nicht, dass man immer übernehmen muss, was der gesagt hat.
Es kann ja auch sein, also zum Beispiel hat erst die Begegnung mit Vertretern anderer Disziplinen in diesem direkten Austausch dazu geführt,
dass ich mich von so einem ganz engen Kanon der wissenschaftlichen Literatur lösen konnte.
Weil ich dachte, okay die haben den gleichen, also die haben einen ganz anderen Kanon, aber die haben auch diesen großen Kanon,
der unbedingt gelesen und abgearbeitet werden muss.
Und da dachte ich, wenn den alle haben, was ist denn dann eigentlich verbindlich?
Dann kann ich doch auch sagen, okay ich verlasse mich dann auf mein Urteil und bilde den eigenen Kanon dazu
und das ist ja auch ein Prozess in der Promotion und dem wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten allgemein.
Aber das war dann immer sehr anregend und manchmal eben auch so, wie sagt man, …
Inspirierend?
Ja, inspirierend, aber auch so, dass es Dinge wieder in die rechten Verhältnisse gerückt hat.
Man kann sich ja auch extrem …
Kalibrierend.
Ja genau.
Man kann sich ja auch auf so kleinste Kleinigkeiten fokussieren und da Stunden und Tage und Wochen damit verbringen
und hinterher denkt man, okay das hat dich jetzt interessiert?
Und dann merkt man, okay eigentlich das war jetzt schon ganz schön nerdig, also ist auch nerdig, aber da noch kleiner reinzugehen.
Zurück zum Wesentlichen sozusagen.
Ja.
Alina Kokoschka, ich sage, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zur islamischen Ästhetik.
Und auch dem Ausblick, was kulturwissenschaftliche Forschung so künftig eigentlich noch für Herausforderungen hat,
insbesondere wie sie sich organisiert.
Ganz herzlichen Dank für die Einladung.
Und ich sage natürlich auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Das war es für heute, bald geht es wieder weiter.
Bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.